March 9th 2016 a Japanese weather
satellite orbiting high above the
Pacific Ocean captures a gigantic dark
shape moving across the earth looks kind
of like the spacecraft from the
Independence Day movie right before it
obliterates the city this it's
gargantuan
the black shape is almost 3,000 miles
wide the satellite tracks it moving
rapidly across the surface of the ocean
there's this giant black area almost the
size of Australia you got to wonder
what's causing that
the satellite tracks the dark shape for
four hours but then it mysteriously
disappears a clue to the mystery lies in
the date the image was captured the
shadow occurred during a rare and
inspiring celestial event
could this be responsible for the
darkening over the Pacific
on March 9 2016 there was a solar
eclipse this is when the moon comes in
between the Sun and the earth kinda like
my fist coming between me and the camera
and a shadow then appears on the earth
the dark shape is nothing less than the
shadow of the Moon as seen from space it
occurred over the Pacific Ocean and over
Indonesia you can see the shadow moving
across the surface of the earth during a
total eclipse the moon casts a shadow
around 3,000 miles across that travels
at around 2,000 miles per hour as it
sweeps across the surface of the earth
during his time on the ISS astronaut
Leroy Chiao was one of the few people to
film the spectacle from space we were
told by the ground that there was going
to be an eclipse event and so we were
kind of ready for it and as I looked at
the window I saw this dark spot moving
pretty rapidly across the earth it did
feel a little eerie because you know you
there's not very often that you get to
observe it and eclipse event from space
so you don't really appreciate the how
big that shadow is that's moving across
the earth it's amazing to see what an
eclipse looks like from space
you
you